so for this song I'm playing Olean aalo
first came to the United States from
Nigeria 15 years ago to study medicine
but his musical talent and the growing
popularity of the afro beat sound took
him in a completely different direction
to the stage and the studio there he and
his band The Kingsmen have backed up
some of the most popular African artists
of the day including three of the five
nominated for a Grammy award in the
newly created category of best African
music performance among them Ira star
when I first came it wasn't as popular
but um over time it started growing and
growing artists like whiskid you know D
Vito burner boy they kind of broke that
boundary you know they they broke that
door and it kind of just became very
popular the past couple of years African
musicians have a long history of being
recognized at the Grammy Awards for many
different styles of music but this year
for the first time time ever they have
their very own category and it's
dominated by Nigerian afro beats the
genre caught the attention of the
recording Academy after exceeding 15
billion streams on the music platform
Spotify obviously a level of quality
that we look at but also critical mass
of the amount of recordings being
created and consumed and we know just
looking at data looking at uh streaming
flat platforms and other ways of
analyzing it that this music is very
popular there's a ton of really talented
people making it it's highly creative
people like The Kingsmen who are getting
ready to record their own original afro
beats music it's a blend of different
genes you know Hip-Hop soul pop
classical music jazz but when you blend
that and now have um the African sound
surrounding that you know it's it's
that's kind of Afro beats you know a
sound that knows no
borders Kristen salumi Al jazer New
York make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer